Denny Hamlin and I'll have him talk
about it but we make way for Bubba
Watson the great golfer did you ever
play golf with Michael Jordan have I no
I've never played with Michael hung out
with him a couple of times but never
never hit any balls with him I wonder
how that would be where cuz he openly
trash-talks and I don't know if you've
gotten into those that you know matches
where you're with non golfers who talk
trash listen I'm there's one thing I'm
good at I'm good at office right I might
not be very good at golf I can out talk
to you I can tell you that much but do
you do that with Tiger oh oh anybody yes
and there's certain guys even on tour in
tournament competition because we're
having fun right I mean it's an
entertainment business and there's
certain guys there's a handful of guys
where I can I can we can poke fun at
each other while we're in a main event
right and not just a practice round and
so yeah it gets fun that definitely gets
fun when you see that guy you're paired
with that guy as you know you can joke
around with and poke fun at actually
it's really fun if not you then who's
the king of trash-talking only go of
course oh I mean I mean Tigers got
eighty two victories he's really the
king but uh you know I'd have to say
Matt Kuchar Matt Kuchar is he's good at
it and he does it like he's smiling at
you he's got everybody fake that that's
a fake smile by the way I'll go and tell
you that Matt Kuchar smile
I can't imagine Matt Kuchar being
mean-spirited hey did you get you fool
he does he does because he he's always
got the smile they're yelling coach but
meanwhile he's at he's jabbing you a
little bit yeah while he's smiling at
you and you're like just you get so mad
at it oh yeah the reason why I was
curious about Michael Jordan because I
was looking at the experience that you
guys are offering Ewing Denny Hamlin's
so explain that to the audience what the
experience is the Olin challenge and
then how they can take part in this yes
so on Denny Hamlin where
pretty good friend and he's a little
lefty golfer and you know he came up
with this idea and I said man I'm I'm
all-in which is the name of the thing
but he said we're gonna I'm gonna let
people come and play golf with me at
Michael Jordan's course because him and
Michael Jordan lived in Charlotte
together and they're good friends and so
he said we're gonna do it at the Michael
Jordan course Grove 23 and I said man
I'll come down I played and you know and
I've given away one of my watches that I
have in my collection
Rashard mil 3901 wait wait those are
those are really expensive yeah this one
this one they're hard to come by and
that this one's roughly I will just say
roughly a hot you know somewhere around
150 150 thousand for this watch
and so donated that donated the round
the golf and then Denny's
taking them on to who's done pretty well
at Daytona
I think three-time winner yeah Daytona
and he's gonna take him there for an
experience of a lifetime hang out and
his you know hit the FedEx box which is
right there by him and go meet his crew
meet him I'm gonna get a fire suit that
he wears in the car and then I think he
actually if I remember correctly is
going to take him for a hot lap maybe
drive him around in the car for a second
yeah I mean this is a experience that
you get to play golf with Denny and
shoot the breeze with him here at trash
talk between me and him and then and
then get to play golf with me and then
get in a cool watch out of it and a cool
fire shoot out of it I actually have one
of Denny's then he had me a fire suit
made I've never been in a race car but I
have a fire suit just in case I guess
well you got to do a ride-along with
Hamlin I don't trust it listen you're
talking about a car real fat he told me
he but he he would hang me two inches
from the wall and I said I'm out
so he'll make you throw up Bubba oh for
sure there's this thing you know I live
in Pensacola Florida where the Blue
Angels are and they ask me all the time
and I said no I'm not going up in the
blue you know so this all-in challenge I
mean the way it came about
michael rubin just had an idea and we're
talking about you know his his ultimate
goal would be a hundred million and when
you start seeing like this morning drake
got involved i saw Ellen was involved
yesterday I mean just all these people
coming together trying to feed all walks
of life and this this pandemic and so
everybody's trying to do a good thing
and and and hopefully it turns out well
I saw we just went over not we but the
whole organization went over six and a
half million I think so it's starting I
mean only three days or four days in its
starting that on a good pace that's
great
yeah so it's called the all-in challenge
is that the website or you go to
fanatics calm I think you can go to
fanatic but there is a website all-in
challenge calm okay and then that might
transfer you over but yeah so it shows
all the different things there's one you
know it's only ten bucks so you can buy
a raffle ticket
I guess it's like a raffle ticket or
your name in a hat for these ultimate
chat these ultimate things you can get
like get a co-host with Ellen you know
you can be in movies with Kevin Hart in
the screen Leonardo DiCaprio for only
ten bucks and then you can buy in the
experience as well you know what options
part of it well you got two green
jackets you don't need to so why not
throw in a green jacket like a loner
exactly hey I'm trying to hang on to
mine just so I can prove to everybody
did you watch this past weekend when
Tiger was there with Jim Nantz and so he
was looking back on when he won the
Masters last year I did not see that I
wasn't so fine watching mine as well it
was so good because you know Tiger
doesn't share too much and to understand
what he is thinking in the moment it was
just it was really fascinating than the
previous day they did when Phil won the
Masters in 2004 where he was the the
analyst there with Jim Nantz oh it was
well known yeah it it was it was good
stuff now Phil loves to talk Tiger
usually doesn't love to talk his Tigers
still blocking your text messages
because you send stupid text messages to
him yeah he ignores me a lot of time
I will say though I will I'll give you
one little tidbit okay after he won the
Masters last year in nineteen he sent me
at you know I came down from the
champions locker and was right there
when he got to the scoring area there's
a few of us golfers right six seven of
us golfers in and and we went down there
say hey to him and he said hey and we
talked and then he had a good sound a
scorecard right he sent me a text
the the next week and I should have
saved it now that I think about it but
um he said that thank you so much it
means so much that you would wait around
while you know when I won and that was
probably that's probably the nicest
words ever got from him normally you
know they're they're a lot meaner but um
they showed it on the broadcast they
showed it all you guys they're waiting
for Tiger yeah yeah I was it was a cool
moment yeah that you guys wanted to wait
to congratulate yeah I mean you're
talking about I mean in our sport I mean
that's that's um the best ever you know
that the who I've got to see I didn't
get to see Jack in his heyday and so
waiting around was no big deal I end up
finished at 11th so I was you know a
couple couple groups in front of them so
now it was easy to wait around and watch
one of the greatest and a person I call
a friend you know it was then it was
cool to get that that text I mean it was
it was nice that he he would reach out
especially after winning I'd still be
celebrating I'm still celebrate much
well when you played Augusta in a month
other than April have I yeah um yeah at
University of Georgia we used a clay we
got to go once a year so we played in
February I usually take a couple friends
usually somewhere between January to
April so I've rotated depending on where
my time off is before the Masters so
I've played in a couple months earlier
you know that same year which they're
gonna be like in November gosh I think
that they're so talented and they're on
their crew I think it's going to be
unbelievable looking just like it is
normally but I think that you know
obviously the lead
and the trees will look a little
different more more of a winter fall
feel but I think you'll still be
spectacular
I mean Augusta when I not let the beauty
of that course go away if that makes
sense
you got the PGA in June what do you
think the I was wondering about social
distancing that like golf could pull
this off there's no gallery and it's
just you and your caddy and then you
know you're in a twosome here or maybe
you carry your own bag I don't know but
I it feels like golf could could do this
tennis could do this as well what do you
think about the PGA in June yeah I mean
this is it's all this is all new to all
of us
right and I with the new schedule just
came out like gosh I would say an hour
ago revised schedule so the first event
would start June 8th in Texas yeah
colonial yeah and so yeah I mean this is
um it's just something we've never had
to deal with as a society so this is all
new but yeah golf could do it yeah
you're right I think tearing the bag
yeah you could easily keep away get more
people away doing that but um can I have
to add my own number so I'd be lost
so that would be tough but uh golf you
could do it tennis you could do it I
could see that for sure but golf I'm in
the trees a lot and most of the guys are
in the fairway
well I'm away anyway so have you ever
hit a shot where you go oh my god and
I'm a professional golfer like the worst
shot you ever hit man I hit many of
those I mean the most famous one is
number 10 at Augusta in 2012 I mean I'm
trying to get up a 50-yard slice and I
hit a you know a 15-yard draw so I
missed my target by a little bit there
it worked out in my favor but any time
you sat it in the water I've added one
in the water at Bay Hill Arnold Palmer's
course on number 18 where isn't shopping
them of the fairway just as it went
about 30 yards right in the middle of
water
I never say anything to try to cheer you
up or just go oh my god that's so bad
yeah he'll kill lines they are I think
that was an old divot you were in old
divot yeah it's a great thing that you
and Danny are doing and all these
athletes and celebrities it's fanatics
dot-com and also the all-in
challenge.com a lot of great items on
there if you want to go to Michael
Jordan's golf course and you want to
play with Denny Hamlin and Bubba and
also Daytona 500 package there and
everything that goes along with that a
lot of good stuff it's great to catch up
with you again Bubba hope the family's
well and we appreciate your time yeah
thank you thank you
all y'all stay safe man that's a Bubba
Watson